the whole purpose of this is to set up
today's draft yeah the best corners in
the nfl right now inspired by the news
of the xavian howard deal uh do what do
we do when we're in person we're not
doing rock paper scissors we're not
please so let's save the audio ahead so
we're going to break big coin toss go
ahead
why don't you start picking you can
start picking go ahead maybe i don't
want to do no then it'd be then because
i'm not going to buy it i'll really be
ready i'm i'm on fire lately okay this
is easy i'm going jaylen ramsey number
one yep i know jaylen ramsey's the best
corner in the nfl jalen ramsey really
became the best corner in the nfl for me
about halfway through his rookie year
but you know you're talking about a guy
that really has just about all or
everything you want out of a top tier
corner in football size speed you know
physicality you know swagger and a big
mouth that's at least what i like in my
corners i mean jalen ramsey man-to-man
uh yeah he's one of the best shutdown
corners in all the sport and really
there's no receiver that's a mismatch
for him he can match up with the antonio
browns if you're seeing the highlights
here he can match up with the bigger
more physical receivers like a deandre
hopkins if he has to he can play zone he
can play man he is truly a special
talent he tackles which is rare for a
corner as well
and really is one of the tone setters
for that jacksonville jaguar defense but
yeah you give me one guy to cover any
receiver in football i'm taking jalen
ramsey there's been a weird vibe between
ramsey and the jaguars over the past
year or two but even with that he's
still the best at what he does and the
idea that the jaguars would ponder a
future without him a little asinine but
at some point think it's coming soon
right to be there does he that's yeah
that's the real question does he want to
be there or does he want to play for
someone else because if he don't if he
wants to you finish a rookie contract
you go year to year under the franchise
tag or you wait for them to trade and
get value it's almost an obj situation
where at some point the organization
gets exasperated and says we got to move
on all right a a guy who was a first
round pick back in 2012 i believe stefan
gilmore yeah and i remember when he
became a free agent
and the patriots pounced on him was kind
of a surprise he wasn't like the bears
were in the mix there were a few other
teams out there when the patriots make
that rare move to go get a guy and pay
market value they will swoop in out of
nowhere we didn't expect it to happen
with stefan gilmore and i remember
saying at the time you know what they
have dealt with stefan gilmore twice a
year for every year of his career yeah
they know what they're getting they know
who this guy is right they've they've
coached against and they've scouted him
they deal with him they see something
there that justifies the payment it was
a little rocky at first
but i think he's become one of the very
best if not the best you can make the
argument he is better than than jaylen
ramsey yeah i mean he is phenomenal i
mean uh i should be making that argument
i should be saying you should have taken
stefan gilbert well i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna argue that he's certainly in
this conversation i mean gilmore i don't
know if there's a corner in football
that has more pressure on him on a
play-by-play basis i mean the new
england patriots they match up stuff on
gilmore man to man i mean almost all
game every game throughout the whole
year and if he's not playing the team's
number one receiver he's playing the
number two receiver and he's on an
island by himself and uh yeah the new
england patriots expect a lot out of him
as a player and that's why they paid him
so much money we don't always see them
pay free agents that type of money that
tells you how special that position is
for the patriots and how they want to
kind of formulate their defense so uh i
can't push back here i doubt i'm going
to be pushing back against many of these
people on this list regardless because
these are the best corners in football
i'm going to go with the guy that just
signed though i'm gonna go with xavier
howard as my next guy i really do he's
been a guy that's been on my radar
anybody that's listened to you know
chris sims unbuttoned or anything i've
said on podcast i always thought this
guy was in the conversation for one of
the best corners in football and hey you
know me and you've heard us we've talked
about this a lot through the draft i'm
all about first thing is if i'm going to
pay you to be one of the best corners in
football you better be able to play
man-to-man and i've ever better be able
to leave you on an island by yourself
you know 40 50 times a game against the
best receivers in football and you'll be
okay and that's what xavier howard does
whether it's been against the patriots
interceptions like that you know you see
him covering t y hilton man-to-man but
again another guy like the guys we've
already talked about that have pretty
good size so they're never outmatched by
the bigger receivers but have incredible
quickness for their size to go along
with it xavier howard is one of the best
man-to-man cover corners in the sport
yeah and you know the issue with him
though is durability that's the one
knock and and you if you look at his
contract and you wonder well why did he
sign a six-year deal that pays out less
than 13 million a year i mean again it's
a guy who had never gotten huge money
right and second round pick out a bill
when it's on the table that's right it's
so hard to say no to it yes if you are
yeah it doesn't take much of a
cost-benefit analysis to realize that's
a lot of money right that you're walking
away from right all right uh a guy who
wants a lot of money but who isn't
currently getting it from the denver
broncos i got to go chris harris jr okay
chris harris jr even though i mean as of
right now he may not be a guy who
deserves 15 million a year well into the
future but he's a guy who as of right
now is one of the best corners in the
game he he plays inside he plays outside
he's got a chip on his shoulder he's you
know tough he's gritty he was undrafted
he and he's the kind of guy that
helps uh inspires a defense right
because look at what this guy's been
through look at what this guy's
accomplished and he holds his own
against anyone that he covers
and when when they had their super bowl
run a few years ago remember that night
they shut down aaron rodgers now he had
a key yeah sure no but shut down aaron
rodgers 75 yards or something like that
so i i think chris harris jr who yes
he's getting a little senior as nfl
corners go but i still think he's got a
few good years left as right now he's
one of the best yeah he's one of the
best i mean i i would probably say that
to you if i was gonna try to knock this
down and make sure i win this draft i
would go uh gosh i don't know if i could
put him up in the class as some of the
other guys would just because of the
years thing but he's still phenomenal i
mean he still deserves more money and
you know the great value with chris
harris jr unlike some of these other
guys we're talking about too is he has
more nickel value i mean his ability to
cover the slot receiver is really where
he made a name for himself i mean for a
number of years he was the number one
nickel cover corner in football uh which
is very tough because of course
a slot receiver is in the middle of the
field he can go either way the
sideline's not there to help you and uh
chris curse harris jr did a good job of
kind of mastering that position okay so
this is where it gets interesting here
hmm
i think okay i'm really torn here
because there's there's two guys i like
but i think i'm going to go with it i'm
going to go with the other corner down i
knew it jackson i knew it i'm going to
go with aj bouilla yeah i mean the
jacksonville jaguars have two of the
five best corners in the sport but aj
bouier for me is in that conversation i
mean he is a phenomenal football player
again
a guy that we saw in houston before he
came to jacksonville and this is why he
got the big payday is he could cover and
man up against the best guys in the
sport and you would feel comfortable
about it 27 years old got good height
size everything like that but there's
just not going to be very many
mismatches this is what makes the
jacksonville jaguars defense so special
because they can trust guys like booyah
and ramsey to be on the outside and go
okay you play man-to-man and we can do
everything else we want to do in the
middle of the field however that works
out so they're they're always in a
comfortable position as far as
man-to-man cover cornerbacks but aj
bouier uh is big time and i do think he
deserves to be on this list now
you know yeah this this is difficult now
there are some guys with recognizable
names right who maybe have fallen off
and then you've got some up-and-comers
got some up-and-comers i know you know
if we put this on twitter like if i go
desmond king people can go who's desmond
king right you know i um let me mommy
throw you some names that are at least
were like in my i mean patrick peterson
patrick peterson just because of of what
he's done do it that's his thing
with that yeah that that's
even though
see and and i can never tell
when a guy feels like he's slipping is
that because he just doesn't have the
help around him yeah are we not paying
attention to him right you know the best
corners you never hear their name during
a game you're right because they never
are thrown off but he tests them you're
right no he is still i'm not going to
say he's patrick peterson from four or
five years ago but to to the point of
what you're saying with all these guys
in this list he's still a
they could put him on the best guys in
the sport and go
you got him and we'll figure out what to
do with the other 10 guys but we know
you're covering if you're watching on tv
brandon cook's man-to-man and we feel
good about it you'll shut him down and
then we'll figure out how to stop other
things that's what a great coroner does
that's what patrick peterson's been
doing since day one of his nfl career
you're not wrong in taking him there i
mean he's still the man other names at
least thought about like byron jones
dallas cowboys right i think he's there
william jackson uh for the cincinnati
bengals a guy i don't think a lot of
people know about that is really a
special corner kyle fuller for the
chicago bears he's pretty awesome too
those are all and marshawn lattimore for
the saints those were guys that at least
were uh honorable mentions well
lattimore was the defensive rookie of
the year in 2017 but last year that was
great secondary fell off yeah the saints
last year agreed yeah i i um yeah
all right let's recap jaylen ramsey
xavien howard and aj bouier for chris
i've got stefan gilmore chris harris jr
patrick peterson uh that we may feel
very differently about that list during
or after the 2019 season but as of right
now i think that that that makes a lot
of sense and you know it's a position
where guys come and go they do really
quickly and you can fall off the top of
the mountain not long ago richard
sherman was the top of the mountain
that's not even in the conversation it's
a i get pushback from this a lot from
fans who go well two years ago you said
this guy was the best corner yeah and i
go well yeah but that was two years ago
which is like seven eight years of real
life time for an nfl football player
think about that except for quarterbacks
right quarterbacks and and offensive
tackles right it tends to stay constant
at the other positions it can change
very very quickly right i think with
receivers it tends to stay it does seem
to yeah defensive backs running backs
yep linebackers like you you're the
flavor of the month of the week flavor
the moment and that's it yup
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports